now we have an update on the health of
Pennsylvania Senator John fetterman he
has admitted himself into the hospital
to receive treatment for clinical
depression this is a condition that
affects millions of Americans and many
of the Senator's colleagues have been
supportive Scott McFarland is on Capitol
Hill Scott good morning this is
certainly another setback for the
Senators good to see that people on both
sides of the aisle are supporting him
today that's right Gail good morning
Senator fetterman's spokesman says the
senator checked himself into the Walter
Reed National military Medical Center
upon the recommendation of the office of
attending physician of Congress this is
the latest in a series of recoveries the
senator is making including a stroke he
suffered while campaigning for the
Senate last spring he was also
hospitalized last week for
lightheadedness and now he's receiving
inpatient treatment for depression the
National Institutes of Health say more
than 20 million Americans suffered an
episode of depression in 2020 and
there's research showing approximately
one in three stroke survivors can be
impacted by depression veterans
announcement has sparked a strong
outpouring of support from his
colleagues who say the stigma around
depression too often causes it to go
untreated this statement from New York
Congressman Richie Torres says he would
not be alive let alone in Congress if it
weren't for mental health care
the U.S Surgeon General also issued a
statement saying he hopes Senator
fetterman's courage will serve as an
example for others Tony yeah there is
help out there Scott thank you very much